hey everybody welcome to the stream we
have today scheduled for the top of the
hour Donald Trump's press secretary
Kayleigh maghen anyhoo will be a
briefing us briefing the press briefing
America with lies as we have seen many
times before and we will see how
cartoonish they are scheduled for 16
minutes from now could be an hour from
now we don't know she's often very very
late but that's okay because we have so
many things to discuss here in the
United States first globally update on
coronavirus numbers were approaching 6
million official cases we are close to
three hundred and sixty thousand deaths
we continue to see looking at
yesterday's numbers Brazil
challenging the United States for the
most new cases per day yesterday Brazil
actually with more new cases in the
United States deaths lagging behind we
still have 1500 deaths a day here in the
US but Brazil look at this curve as you
can see not looking good in Brazil at
all and there are now discussions about
resignation being demanded from their
president gyre bolson ro it's it's a
mess there Russia also not doing
particularly well as you can see but
they have actually maybe turned the
corner if you can believe this data
although deaths continue to increase
typically that's a lagging indicator and
then India also continuing to struggle
let's see their curve continuing to grow
deaths continuing to grow so here in the
United States we are past 1.75 million
official cases the real number of course
who knows how big it is
102 almost 103 thousand deaths remember
Donald Trump said we would have 60,000
deaths we're now at a hundred and two
and he's still calling this a success
fortunately the one good bit of data is
that some states are really doing okay I
mean I'm pleased with what's happening
in Massachusetts obviously the numbers
are horrifying in the aggregate
but when you look at the trajectory this
is what you want to see when you look at
the trajectory of deaths that's the
direction you want things to go in now
I'm going to show you a number now that
is a sick disgusting embarrassing number
I'm gonna show you the number of tests
the United States did yesterday and you
know we we've been trying to go from
100,000 a day to two to three to four to
five hundred thousand a day today I
interviewed congressman roe kana friend
of the David Pakman show that interview
will air later today make sure you're
getting my audio podcast to get that
right away when it publishes in about an
hour and 45 minutes he believes we need
to be doing you know certainly 5 million
tests a week look at how many tests we
did yesterday two hundred and eighty
five thousand tests we went back
yesterday to the testing level of March
tenth before yesterday you have to go
tomorrow I'm sorry May 10th May tenth
not March tenth well you have to go back
to May tenth to find a day on which we
did as few tests as yesterday excuse me
we can't even get to five hundred
thousand and we need to be at one two
million a day it is absolutely and
completely disgusting we just can't get
it together and you know Trump likes to
say in some places there's too many
tests no one's showing up you need to do
surveillance testing you need to start
saying hey if it's true that we have
this testing capacity if you're over 65
just come get a test if you just cut if
your last name starts with a through D
you can get tested on Monday regardless
of symptoms II threw G well what we need
to be doing surveillance testing we are
nowhere near where we need to be okay
one other thing let me just see how
we're doing in terms of if anything has
gone live here not quite yet okay one
other thing and actually let me do a
couple of Super chats because I see that
I've fallen behind on them already and
then I will I will get back to something
else I want to talk about out of New
York let's see been abusing says what
total percentage of trumps waking hours
consists of makeup spray tan tanning bed
hairpiece maintenance cable TV Twitter
Golf good trumpet alpha-male I mean from
up from reports that I've seen on
weekdays Trump is watching five to seven
hours of cable TV you know add a couple
more hours to that it's probably you
know 80% of the day that he's awake for
Walker Anderson says why do protestors
automatically assume police racism you'd
have to ask them Kevin Macomber says
college shouldn't be free but much
cheaper most degrees won't get you a
well-paying job and you would be better
off working what are your thoughts yeah
well so the problem is that the cost of
a college degree has gone completely out
of sync with expected earnings in many
fields and so that's that's a huge
problem
it's a wages problem but it's mostly a
college cost problem and that is
something that we absolutely need to be
considering Walker Anderson says police
brutality isn't racism by default right
no you can have police brutality that
does not involve racism that's true
Walker Anderson says just curious on
your opinion I respect you all right
well I just gave it to you Azim Abu
Khalil says congratulations on
surpassing secular talk subscriber
count'
I didn't know that a million is at hand
the more people listening to you the
better hope you're well yeah I don't I
don't know how other channels are doing
subscriber wise I know we have had of a
huge surge very powerful surge recently
we are at 844 thousand if enough of you
subscribe we could get to 8:45 during
the stream actually I'm sort of focused
on our own numbers I would love to be at
a million subscribers by November it's
gonna be very tight it's gonna be very
very tight drew Goldfarb says David you
should add an on screen like ount er
yeah we I don't I think it would just be
going off the hook like a UH like a slot
machine but it is a good idea
Sabrina safar says no haircut yet no no
haircut yet you know I usually get my
hair cut outside of of my home area
there's a particular place that I go so
I'm gonna have to probably wait a little
bit but but maybe within a week or ten
days or something like that I will get
myself a haircut okay let's take a look
at a recent report from four
Forbes Cuomo will let New York
businesses deny customers without masks
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo said in a
Thursday press conference he will sign
an executive order allowing businesses
to deny customers who are not wearing
masks contrasting with businesses across
the country that have said the exact
opposite and will not serve customers
who are wearing the protective gear can
you imagine something more dumb Cuomo
says you don't want to wear a mask fine
then you don't have a right to enter
that store so I'm actually confused
about this because my understanding of
the law and if there's something in New
York State that is different than this I
want to hear about it
my understanding is businesses can deny
service to whoever they want to deny
service to as long as the denial is not
based on the customers membership in a
protected class so for example if you
want to say no black people allowed no
Jews allowed in my business that would
be against the law because we have
established non-discrimination laws as
far as that goes in some states you are
not allowed to say if you're gay you're
not allowed to come into my business
although that is allowed in some states
this is America and that's still allowed
in some states so I don't actually know
why you would even need this executive
order because political orientation is
not a protected class if you want to say
no Trump is allowed in my store if you
had a way to figure that out that that
would be allowed
I believe Washington DC considers
political orientation protected but I
believe what other states do not along
the same lines if you say I don't want
people not wearing a shirt in my store
certainly we're all familiar with the no
shirt no shoes no service signs so I
don't know why Cuomo even needs to say
anything that says if a store wants to
say no mask no service I don't know why
you need an executive order for that now
there are situations where something can
be a proxy to a protected class so let
me give you a hypothetical imagine that
only black people were wearing masks and
you banned masks as a proxy to banning
black people okay
now we have something to talk about but
again my understanding of the of the law
is that there is nothing that would
prevent a business from refusing service
to someone on the basis of not wearing a
mask much the same way that a business
can say if you're not wearing shoes
you're not allowed in my store if you're
not wearing a shirt you're not allowed
in my store so I'm a bit confused about
that but maybe we can get a legal
explanation that makes a little more
sense at some point soon for those of
you who join me yesterday we we
attempted to go live with the launch of
the Falcon 9 rocket pushing or bringing
delivering the Dragon spacecraft to the
International Space Station that launch
was scrubbed due to weather the next
launch window is Saturday it's either 2
or 3 p.m. Eastern Time and I do plan to
be back which is going to be we should
have a fantastic stream let me say a few
thank-yous to folks who are watching on
twitch and doing the extremely kind
thing of subscribing gearbox 42 has
subscribed with twitch Prime and tan
Mane's six eight eight nine has
subscribed for the tenth month in a row
unbelievable thank you so much very much
appreciate that support other super
chats continuing to come in Captain Aiko
says where's the man bun so I agreed to
do a man bun yesterday during my stream
and I did it and it was it was pretty
stunning a lot of people were surprised
a few kids will need therapy
unfortunately because they saw my man
bun but most people just enjoyed it but
I did not promise it a second time ALX
kefka says david what is the status of
operation air bridge yeah i believe that
they have 7,200 flights scheduled
operation air bridge now has 7,200
scheduled flights kevin mccomber says
what are your thoughts on Trump talking
big tech censorship yeah the most
transparent free speech advocate
president in history wants to regulate
and censor what private companies will
be forced to allow on their platform can
you imagine a more trigger Abul
snowflake than Donald Trump it is
unbelievable
thank you to mr. Hillsman
and Nikki who have subscribed with
twitch Prime as a hypetrain gets going
some people refer to it by a different
term it's an ugly term very very ugly
term but we call it a hypetrain
booger-face says on the executive order
may be because of the Karen's no offense
to anyone named Karen I don't know what
you were talking about I don't know what
you're talking about and let me see if I
can actually find the full text of the
executive order I'm not actually finding
that yet I don't know if it's been
revealed yet or not but we we will
certainly be covering it jay-ar says
David you are the Lord and soul of
Reason rationalization good reason and
logic redundant I realize on all your
full shows you are my go-to for accuracy
and sane and proper perspective thank
you I am I am undeserving of that degree
of praise Ron says why does Bernie not
get criticism for voting for the crime
bill the way Biden does that's a fair
question
I don't I don't know the answer I
interviewed roe Khanna today and he was
a Bernie Sanders co-chair and he says he
said I'm gonna preach this is this is
the hot take from ROH Khanna and we're
publishing this a little bit later today
ROH Khanna said it is privileged
privileged for Bernie supporters to say
yeah let's let Trump win because it
might help progressives at some point in
the future that's not my words I've
never said that Rokon a Bernie Sanders
co-chair and progressive darling of the
House of Representatives said to me
today it is a sign of is it an act of
privilege to say now let's give Trump
another four years because we think it
might be advantageous in 2024 we will be
publishing that later today I expect a
lot of wackiness and craziness in
response let's see here
mave jack says did you see the lady
stabbing looters outside target I did
not I did not see that and I don't know
that I want to pull it up right now it
might I don't know what isn't isn't
allowed on various stream elements so
I'm gonna wait on that
Sam Dean says
d-david ready for another round of
nonsense we are indeed Matt Chavez says
Trump expediting Floyd investigation is
merely an attempt to steal votes granted
it's a good thing but the reason to act
on a national story is clear of course
of course
listen if you want to see how someone
behaves when they actually understand
the issue of racial discrimination by
law enforcement look at what joe biden
said today joe biden is no perfect
candidate i'm way to his left you all
know the talking points insert talking
points and and disclaimers here but joe
biden came out and immediately said
listen this is not an isolated incident
and while the isolated incident needs to
be dealt with this is emblematic of
something that has been a problem in the
united states for a long time
unless and until we deal with the root
causes and the systemic causes we're not
really going to stop this type of thing
from happening and like that's the kind
of statement i would like to see from a
president we're not gonna get that from
donald trump certainly ever ever thanks
to Frisco Jones and Nour vie for the
support over on Twitch thank you to a
nice epic off for subscribing on YouTube
also Sargent leska says hi from
Australia we appreciate your efforts
David keep up the good work soldier
salutes Thank You sergeant very very
much appreciate that
good to hear from you a couple of other
things oh I've got some sean hannity
video check out sean hannity having two
clips where he actually makes some sense
here's hannity saying why the hell
aren't these partiers wearing masks or a
lake of the ozarks packed with
partygoers
this holiday weekend look i understand
these young people experts keep saying
over and over they're at a much lower
risk but if they do get this and again
there's no mass wearing here that i see
or not much at all
I see no social distancing but if they
get the virus then are in contact with
older and more vulnerable Americans that
could be a disaster for others that's
why in a short period of time it's only
temporary yep you can't social distance
please wear the mask do it for your mom
your dad your grandma your grandpa Sean
Hannity making a little bit of sense
despite being overall a weaponized
propagandist here is also Sean Hannity
commenting on the George Floyd situation
always any opportunity Hannity gets to
talk about his martial arts training for
the last seven years he does it but he's
still saying some things that make sense
here take a look and again this is not
trial by videotape here that has nothing
to do with it
this guy's not resisting on any video we
see you hear him clear clearly saying I
can't breathe right isn't I have to
imagine and I talk to but my martial
arts sensei there it is his sensei
trains police officers for free he says
it is scary to him how for most officers
a lot of officers their only option is
what's on their their side arm that's it
or a stun gun they're not trained in the
use of martial arts but even if root
immense retraining would say would you
would know how sensitive this is to
one's neck yes this is not knocking
shocking shocking this is so agree the
way I would say it is not Hannity is a
good guy now I would say this is so
egregious that even weaponized
propagandist Sean Hannity can't
reasonably get away with anything other
than that commentary it that that's
where we are right now and you know
broken clocks can be right once a day or
twice a day depending on whether it's a
you know 24-hour clock ER anyway you
guys get the point it it is what I'm
seeing people saying even rush limbaugh
wasn't defending the cops I that's great
if that's true that's crazy I didn't
know that but yeah okay Zachary Breeland
says Donald Trump retweeted a video
saying the only good Democrat is a dead
Democrat saw it toxic
big SOS man says Jesse Lee Peterson is
your intellectual superior great go
watch his channel I don't know why
you're here if if you believe that to be
the case it looks as though the Kaylie
Magga nanny briefing has been now
rescheduled for the bottom of the hour
can anybody get me a tweet or
confirmation of that if that is the case
anybody know
would love to would love to know a
little bit about that myself
anybody anybody where could we see that
we don't know
did anybody tweet about it maybe in the
meantime I'm gonna kick on the AC here
because it is very very warm I'm gonna
add some elements of cooling if you guys
don't mind there we go
what temperature do you guys think I
should said I love 72 that's typically
my favorite uh my favorite temperature
there we go
all right seventy-two it is very very
good okay it seems as though maybe this
has been rescheduled for the bottom of
the hour but we will be here chatting
and discussing things until that time
thank you okay let me say thank you to
Ben Busic Ben Beussink has grabbed a
membership at join pakman.com the top
website for david pakman show membership
thank you to Ben very much appreciate
that
let's see Bernie Sanders says we need
someone on the left to debate steven
crowder okay let's see
Eila bail says did you see the swiss
curve such a beautiful curve the best
curve let's take a look at that I want
to see what's going on in Switzerland
where is Switzerland here Switzerland
here it is let's take a look at what's
going on in Switzerland 30,000 cases
about 2,000 deaths Wow that is that is
amazing actually that is incredible
good for Switzerland I've not been
following Switzerland closely but that
is unbelievable
as few as oh that's current infections
let's see in recent days Wow 10 you can
you imagine 10 new cases like in
Massachusetts and other states we
regularly have 10 new cases just like in
one nursing home nevermind in the entire
state or country it's unbelievable
that's world emitters dot info world ah
meters dot info for people who are
asking about that that is really really
incredible ok a couple of other things
that I wanted to play for you guys let
me find them over here
i bookmarked a bunch of different things
oh okay
so listen I don't know if this is gonna
be interesting to people but one of the
things I'm gonna do on tomorrow's
program is I'm going to do a segment
about what would be the left-wing case
against lockdowns now it's it's going to
be this is a you know a thought
experiment the question is going to be
is there a left perspective that would
be sensibly skeptical of a full extended
lockdown I believe the answer is yes and
I'm going to you know debunk all of the
bad right-wing arguments against
lockdowns and essentially what what I
will propose tomorrow is the left comes
to the defense of understands that the
most vulnerable people in our society
are the working poor lower middle class
you know blue-collar people who have
relatively low levels of market power
who are relatively easily replaced in
their jobs and older folks etc so what I
am going to sort of think about or or
ponder tomorrow is could there have been
a path where we actually properly
protected older folks remember you know
in Massachusetts at one point sixty
percent of the deaths were in nursing
homes we just failed to protect nursing
homes while keeping more businesses open
with social distancing with masks etc
could we not have saved economic
destruction for the most vulnerable
economically while still protecting the
vulnerable and limiting the economic
damage so tomorrow I'm going to the the
point is I'm going to steal man a
possible left-wing argument against
total extended lockdowns without
advocating for them but I think it's
gonna generate some interesting
conversation and I'm always glad to hear
from folks in the audience their
thoughts on that sort of thing let's see
here incredible TV says Wow even Hannity
is being a good faith actor on George
Floyd get Candice Owens on the phone and
tell her she can
making a fool of herself someone show so
Candace Owens blocked me on Twitter a
while ago so I don't know what she does
but someone sent me one of her clips
recently I had no idea that she was
spreading such violent disinformation
about the virus I genuinely I just had
no idea whatsoever and she is and it's
extremely dangerous very very dangerous
let's refresh here because it seems that
the White House channel has now gone
live I'll just turn up the audio here so
that we hear it right away
Eduardo lino Costa has grabbed a youtube
membership Matt Chavez says here in
Arizona my air conditioning is set to 84
degrees it's chilly huh okay Sam Dean
says any thoughts on how spaceforce is
actually using the Starfleet insignia
from Star Trek I mean what kind of
manchild does that it's ridiculous yeah
I mean it's just it's also painfully
stupid that I've not even really done a
lot of discussion about it it's just all
so dumb and it's you know we it's a kid
it's just this is what happens when you
have someone with the intellectual
capacity of a child as president you
know it's a cool space force let's get
the Star Trek logo it's just dumb it's
extraordinarily dumb let me say thanks
to tan net 64 and Ringo Starr 34 for the
support over on Twitch very very much
appreciate that we are standing by for a
press briefing from Donald Trump's
propaganda press secretary Kaley maggin
Annie she calls herself a Christian and
yet she lies constantly I don't know how
that is aligned with her so-called
Christian beliefs she would probably say
well there's some you know greater good
that she's serving by lying for Donald
Trump or maybe she's convinced herself
she's not lying but I believe she's
smart enough to know she is lying and
she just justifies it let me say thank
you to Jason rouse Jason his new member
number two today at join pakman.com very
much appreciate that thanks Jason
booger-face says you'll have to look up
a number or two
sometime example Karen's gone wild I
know you'll get it once you see it okay
jeez I wish I knew what was being said
there I'm confused
Alex Nova son says will they be
including the cast of the weekend at
Bernie's movie for the potential 2020
feature film weekend at Bernie's at
Biden's yes absolutely
mave jack says what's a protest and when
does it become a riot yeah I actually
tweeted that today let's look at what
people answered me what is the line
between protesting and rioting let's see
what people say I'm a black woman police
killed unarmed black people has been
going on a long time protesting does
nothing rioting makes people pay
attention oh so a pro rioter I have no
idea if that Martin Luther King quote is
accurate if you feel the need to bring
guns then it's a riot
riding is wanton destruction of
third-party property and possessions as
well as unstructured physical violence
not complicated
I see a lot of really sheltered folks
here lionizing riots you've never been
exposed to them probably plus you're
white I think they mean you apostrophe
re white I don't know if they're talking
about me but setting things on fire is
not what protesters do you don't writing
is a form of protest Wow you don't the
morning and protest that is so damn
tired in this country that clearly
hasn't changed anything thus far is not
anyone's to judge I don't know
Ike I'm having trouble parsing the
grammar when that protester protest
shifts into anger we need to focus on
and address the cause and not the
outcome oh boy rioting and looting are
absolutely part of protesting not always
but there is a long history of violence
being used when non-violence doesn't
work this will be one of those Pakman
right-wing takes I'm sure I don't know
what this person is talking about
violence is the line you don't fix
George's death with more death and
destruction be better than that assault
theft arson property damage seems like
an obvious red line with charcoal okay
not that I haven't got sympathy for
those enraged to the point of rioting
but I think a protest only
inconveniences as long as it's going on
doesn't leave permanent damage in its
wake
even if you think violence is the only
answer go
against government buildings go against
the police the moment you look go
looting you hurt your own people more
than these four cops ever could man I'm
having a lot of trouble understanding
some of these the line isn't even gray
it's night and day protests are fine
even encouraged rioting looting and
assaulting innocent cops who had nothing
to do with this is juvenile I think most
people involved are ignorant and don't
actually care about the murder of George
Floyd someone says innocent cops Wow
real smart all right so there's there's
I guess an idea anyway of where some
people are drawing the line between a
protesting and rioting let's do a couple
of other super chats let's see here the
one JP says did you see the video of the
woman in the wheelchair trying to stop
the target rioters thoughts on the
altercation I haven't seen that listen
I'm gonna just I don't need a lot of
people to do this I have just been I've
not we've been so busy with the show the
last 24 hours
can someone email me through my website
the wheelchair lady video I've not seen
that some kind of target stabbing that
people I'm just I know I sound like I'm
totally out of it I've just been so busy
I have not seen these yet any of these
relevant videos related to what happened
in Minnesota please email me I want to
see the target wheelchair lady I want to
see the stabbing thing and anything else
you think I should see david pakman.com
there's a contact form I don't want to
pull this stuff up sight unseen on on
the stream because it could be
problematic I don't know what's you know
twitch Twitter YouTube there's different
rules and we don't we don't want to have
a problem right now
Bartek know what Kowski says what is Joe
Rogan studio smell like weed and whey
protein I imagine there was no notable
smell when I when I walked in I couldn't
identify any particular smell X says any
way to do a live commentary of Don
Junior's Instagram feed later its
intellectual and Bigley with elements of
humor maybe later maybe later we would
do something like that jr. says to the
never Biden progressives there is no
moral high ground in allowing Trump to
get reelected well
that's the argument that congressman ro
Cana made on my program today and we'll
be posting that video later I think
you'll find it interesting if not
compelling Chris K says I live in
Minnesota st. Minneapolis st. Paul
protesting is fine looting is not cool
because it seems to just hurt the same
people that you are protesting for all
right here oh she loves you
says Martin Luther King said darkness
cannot drive out darkness only light can
do that hate cannot drive out hate only
love can do that all right a very very
important and uh and relevant do you
guys want to see any more of the tweets
to me about the difference between
protesting and rioting or are we feeling
are we feeling done with that Oh
someone's asking if I love black people
yes I do yes I do
do we want to see more of those tweets
or are we feeling done alright seems a
bunch of people want to see a few more
so let's just take a look at a couple
more of these to me the question was
what's the difference between a protest
and riot protests or demonstrations that
serve the purpose of dissenting with the
status quo rioting is a reactionary
consequence when these protests fail to
bear any fruit okay I believe in I
believe it riding when there is no cause
for example destruction when a football
team wins the Super Bowl this I believe
is the last resort of a body of people
who have had enough it was even local
businesses that were looted it was
Walmart this was a protest I guess you
mean it wasn't local businesses man I'm
just really struggling with some of
these rioting at the end of the days the
response of continued injustice and
social discontent this rioting is not
spontaneous but a response to continued
frustration with police brutality you
know that's actually interesting to me I
mean it's a lot of people will say
destruction of property is rioting and
chants and carrying signs is protesting
or something like that this one is
interesting which is rioting is not
spontaneous when I went to the
University of Massachusetts Amherst and
the Red Sox lost
or the Red Sox won that didn't really
matter oh about a second oh here we go
let's see what's gonna so I want to
start by acknowledging the horrific
tragedy in Minnesota of George Floyd the
the death of George Floyd is absolutely
tragic that video that we saw that I
solved on my staff saw that the
president saw and the president put out
a statement last night that at his
request the FBI and the Department of
Justice are already well into an
investigation as to the very sad and
tragic death in Minnesota of George
Floyd asked for this investigation to be
expedited and greatly appreciate all of
the work done by law enforcement my
heart goes out to George's family and
friends justice will be served I can
tell you that as I'm briefing you at
this moment the president is receiving a
briefing from the Attorney General
dobar on this and the Deputy Director of
the FBI
so that is ongoing on as I began this
briefing secondly I want to transition
and to some news from SBA and Treasury
that was announced that today the US
Small Business Administration in
consultation with the US Treasury
Department announced that it is setting
aside ten billion of round to funding
for the Paycheck protection program to
be lent exclusively to CDFIs those are
Community Development financial
institutions CDFIs work to expand
Economic Opportunity in low-income
communities by providing access to
financial products and services for
local residents and businesses so we're
encouraged to see that and then finally
before taking your questions I wanted to
address what has been going on on
Twitter and with social media oh boy I
believe it is time to quote get the
facts about Twitter and other social
media platforms targeting their bias
against President Trump and
conservatives online if we were to judge
the bias of Twitter and its top
employees by their own words the case
would be an easy one to make
Twitter's head of site integrity has
tweeted that there are quote actual
Nazis in the White House and no
fact-check label is ever applied to this
absolutely outrageous
offensive and false claim made against
the White House and its employees okay
but let's judge Twitter based on their
actions not based on the words of its
top employees and its actions are no
better President Trump recently received
a so-called fact-check label for a tweet
I don't know why it was a false fact
check in an accurate fact check but
nevertheless Twitter moved forward with
it
dance Covino the deputy chief of staff
here was the first user in the history
of Twitter to receive a so-called quote
manipulated media label for posting a
video that played a verbatim clip it is
no coincidence that these two
unbelievable interventions by pretty
sure that was a slowed down video meant
to make I think it was Nancy Pelosi
looks stupid so it was manipulated there
despite being verbatim so to speak and
while big tech is quick to censor the
president quick to censor some of his
top employees they they are very
reluctant it seems to label some of the
actions by Chinese officials some of the
misinformation that has been spread by
China for example bull to move off of
Twitter and move to Google they created
a search engine search engine for the
Chuck Penny's Communist Party which
blacklisted searches for human rights
and allowed for easy surveillance
Facebook and Twitter have both taken
paid advertising that spread
disinformation about China's mass
imprisonment of religious minorities and
Twitter has allowed Chinese officials to
use its platforms to spread in
misinformation about the coronavirus
undermine the pro-democracy protests in
Hong Kong and more and then back in
March already know we're an egregious
one that our US military was responsible
for the spread of the corona virus and
that tweet that disinformation it took
all the way until today when we raised
concerns about it to get a fact check so
they appear to be very hastily eager to
censor President Trump and some of his
employees but Alize but a little
reluctant when it comes to China it's a
bit befuddled
but no one believes in the First
Amendment more than the president the
president will take action to ensure
that big tech does not stifle free
speech the president will be censoring
and controlling Twitter and is the
biggest advocate of the First Amendment
and finally I just want to note one
other action of Twitter that I learned
just before walking out here that on the
Moller report there anti-trump headlines
were anti-trump by a ratio of 76 to 1
that's extraordinary and it's not just
biased aimed at President Trump and his
employees it's also aimed at everyday
Americans it's aimed at the movie
unplanned as Twitter suspended their
account and then came up with an excuse
in the aftermath and then just another
example that by the way I'm allowed to
smile it's a Christian proven right on
their video was taken out of context and
yet these individuals were led were
allowed by Twitter to incite violence
it's very disturbing to see so those are
some of the president's concerns and
with that I will take questions here we
go yes that's a very nice time thank you
yesterday the u.s. hit a hundred
thousand deaths from the corona virus
he's got a coma that happened at around
6 o'clock yesterday evening it took
until about 9:00 in the more
president to recognize that on Twitter
what took him so long if the president
recognized that landmark before we even
hit it the president was the impetus
behind him lowering the flag to
half-staff he did that for several days
I mean and that was an acknowledgment
I'm lowering the flag for three days a
week ago was an advanced acknowledgment
of a milestone hit yesterday got it
hours some odd hours for him to
recognize that and tweet about it for
advance of that benchmark as I noted he
lowered the flag to half-staff right the
president has said you know you
mentioned a hundred thousand but the
president has said one death is too many
right he takes us very seriously he said
before this is the hardest part of his
presidency it's something that new guys
Trump two months ago wore a flag pin
that was his recognition factor
especially this president who has made
so many false and misleading statements
that has put you know fact checkers to
work across the world
I mean he's cluttered some 18,000 false
or misleading state he's gonna attack
the Washington Post if there's any
president out there who should be back
to have any political leader out there
should be fact check isn't it president
Tom and aren't you trying to silence
fact-checking by going after Twitter
like yes well first I would say I
disagree with them all if not almost all
of those assertions that you're making
there because look if you're going to
get into the fact-checking business
there's no one that should be fact
checked more than the mainstream media
that has been continually wrong about a
number of things to give you a list of
some of the most egregious ones so this
is called look at ABC News in December
of 2017 falsely reported that Flynn
would testify that the president
directed him during the campaign to make
contact with the Russians that was false
in 2017 well he didn't end up testifying
email exclusive and were forced to make
on our Corrections cNN's Jim sciutto and
making corrections is good Trump never
correct Trump never apologized as Trump
never takes responsibility
tell federal investigators that the
president knew of the Trump Tower
meeting and there are many more not to
just put the onus on CNN there
if anyone needs to be factored check
that you got an answer tailor their news
outlets that make mistakes from time to
time we owned up to those mistakes we
corrected always
I have many you guys haven't owned up to
I think it's we do on a regular basis
the president never owns up to any of
this never owned us content misleading
statements were outright lies
you have pledged in this briefing room
to never lie to the American people are
you saying that the president the United
States has never lied to the public
before I'm around the president his
intent is always to give truthful
information to the American the media
apologizes for their mistruths I mean
I'm sitting here looking at other
headlines in New York Times saying there
aren't enough ventilators to cope with
the coronavirus in fact we had an excess
of ventilators we've shipped around the
world Washington Post us health system
is showing why it's not ready for a
corona virus pandemic we were ready
there's many more I could get to I could
on the corona virus specifically I could
spend the time question was about
fact-checking Trump not her talking
about the media agree with the firings
of the police officers and does he
believe that they should be prosecuted I
haven't talked to him about that
specifically but let me tell you this
that's you know he was very upset when
he saw that video I was on Air Force One
I don't know if it was the first time he
saw it but he certainly saw it again on
Air Force One right he was a very upset
by it it was egregious appalling tragic
and it prompted him to pick up the phone
or the chief of staff to pick up the
phone and say we need to expedite what
was already an FBI investigation he
wants justice to be served
can you give us an update on when the
president plans to sign the EO on
Twitter and social media and can you
also give us an update on his plans for
China and Hong Kong as well so thank you
first I would note with regard to the
timing of beo that should be later this
afternoon is what we're hoping for
hopefully before 5 p.m. but again it
could change it's still under in the
works but we are getting closer with
regard to Hong Kong I would just say
breeder 8 what I said that six the two
days ago but I would also say that
China's decision to impose a new
national security law and Hong Kong lies
in direct conflict conflict with its
international obligations under the
principles of the legally binding UN
registered sino-british joint
declaration and that secretary Pompeo
determined that Hong Kong does not
warrant different treatment under US
laws because that social media executive
orders gonna be rich honest from the PRC
and then anything further I'd refer you
to the State Department for now
Palmer one more somewhat related house
treatment asked about a minority group
we first like said that correctly does
the president plan to sign that and is
the White House going to treat bills or
does the White House see any concerns
about bills that have been passed by
proxy is not being constitutional so we
wait at first let me say we would
encourage Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats
and others to come back to the hill it's
more productive to have those members
here
the Senate has convened the house can do
the same and they can do it in person
but with regard to the weavers that's a
very important question we haven't
received the bill yet so the president
hasn't been able to look through it and
I won't get ahead of him on announcing
one way or the other on that but I would
note that the Trump administration
continues to take actions to hold the
CCP accountable for its highly
repressive campaign against the we Gers
and other religious and ethnic
minorities oh okay thank you on vaccines
in order to achieve herd immunity you
need about 80 percent of people to get
this vaccine 17 only about 50% of
Americans say they'll work they'll
receive it so will the administration
make the vaccine mandatory so the
vaccine let me just note that we're
working aggressively to get one and we
know we can get one by the end of the
year everything does not depend on a
vaccine i vaccine is an important
component of this but there are also
therapeutics we're seeing there's not
necessarily a tie to reopening and an
increase in cases so that's encouraging
and I would refer you further to Alex a
czar who's made extensive comments on it
backs a lot of those things are lying
here if you guys will make it mandatory
use your federal powers how you use them
potentially to encourage people to get
this vaccine because if you don't have
elderly people immunocompromised folks
they may not be able to go about their
business again right yeah I would have
to talk to the president I haven't
talked to him about his views on making
it mandatory or not so I'd have to talk
to him and get back to you on that yes
they're never gonna Thank You Kelly I
wanted to ask you a question first of
all about the comments send your
statement that you made at the
conclusion of your comments in regards
to George Floyd you said that justice
will be searched for it you said that
justice will be served what do you mean
by that do you mean that this is a
really glitchy feed let's just go to
realize it hasn't come out yet and I
realize but we haven't seen the language
but we have seen reports I work for Fox
and we assume reports that it relates to
the section 230 the Communications
Decency Act and interestingly enough
former Vice President Joe Biden has also
called for the repeal of section 230 he
says that it should be revoked
immediately but as you know an executive
order does not Trump the law the
executive order can't for instance
repeal the law it can't in any way of
men the law so what would be the intent
behind this executive order without
getting ahead of what the president
intends to sign yeah I don't want to get
ahead of that but one thing I will say
more broadly you reference that section
I think that that would it be included
and what I'm about to say
there are various shields in place that
essentially shield some of these social
media companies and allow them to censor
conservative users and we're not able to
see what happens behind those shields
that section was one of those shields
you mentioned so we're looking at ways
to remove those shields to shed some
light on what is happening and some
regulation fine machines
that's generally and broadly the idea
but I won't get ahead on any specific
announcements that should come hopefully
before 5:00 p.m.
John follow up on Jim's question in fact
get Twitter but but first a
clarification has the president spoken
to the family of George Floyd not to my
knowledge
my if he did Oh without my knowledge
that could have happened but not to my
knowledge do you know he intends to will
you get back to us on that I can ask him
and I can get back to you on that and
regarding the the fact-checking because
the president clearly said things in
these tweets that are not true doesn't
do you not acknowledge that no I don't
acknowledge that either since the
governor of California is sending out
ballots to millions of people anyone
living in the state no matter who they
are how they got there that is not true
California is sending out absentee
ballots to registered voters not to
anybody yes that's just not true
so let me address this in detail on the
issue just after that one and I'm going
to lay out some of the president's
concerns and in that I will get to the
California I know you all first I want
to know that there is a Pew study done
that shows there's plenty of reason to
believe that mass and the mass mailing
system that there is fraud they
estimated that approximately 24 million
one out of every eight voters registered
in the US are no longer valid or are
significantly inaccurate so these are
people on who are on voter registrations
that have not been maintained that
applies to people who are registered to
vote and vote in person these are just
people move people this is a crazy
rebuttal it's Nevada just I read about
this last week and it just really struck
me as a perfect example of what the
president is concerned about with
mail-in ballots and the fraud that can
be inherent in that there were ballots
on because Nevada mass mail been out to
voter rolls that were piling up in
apartment complexes outside of apartment
complexes and lost nobody's sending
those in I mean that this is this is
crazed it the question is is there
evidence that significant numbers of
fraudulent ballots are being cast and
the answer is no said she's never seen
anything like these influx of absentee
ballots all of the people had moved or
died when she said
to deliver on her first delivery route
and this happened just recently you can
go read the articles from last week she
found 65 ballots can carry 100 and then
as the week progressed thousands just
sitting and crates I mean this is
extraordinary this is not how we should
be protecting us balance the question is
is there evidence that fraudulent
ballots are being submitted with any
regularity Russ transfer of mail-in
voting and this happened again recently
I think it was last week and mail-in
ballots for South Carolina turned up in
Maryland there's another example of 700
suspicious mail-in ballots and Dallas
and an individual charged with
second-degree felony illegal voting and
he is accused of visiting a woman in
April to coast so the system worked to
actually find and charge people who are
doing the few instances of this okay Wow
there's a New Jersey example of over
3,000 ballots that were seemingly
set-aside and going to California you
mentioned seemingly set aside that also
is completely vague and it could be set
aside by election officials like these
things mean nothing that they reported
that his office had people dropping off
maybe a hundred or 200 ballots at a time
and somehow in LA County a hundred
twelve percent of LA County is
registered to vote so the problem is
this that's not an issue of absentee
ballots so notice that they're mixing
issues of just voter registration with
issues of ballots being sent but the
question is are fraudulent ballots being
returned and the answer is almost none
our everybody in the state that is a
false statement is not correct
will the president correct that
acknowledge that what he said was simply
not true there's the executive order
that was put into place recently by
Gavin Newsom that would auto send to
voter rolls and that would lead to what
the president was suggesting
undocumented immigrants aren't on voter
rolls she's an idiot it's not to
everybody who's to register to vote yes
to everyone including dead people on the
voter rolls including to the mysterious
112 percent in LA County Wow
that's not just everyone that's ever
going to be really dumb to fall for this
which is why it's perfect for Trump
supporters it's a very concern about the
security of our elections but when it
comes to mail-in ballots all of a sudden
the concern for election
security just melts away friends
research on on mail-in ballots research
has shown that one it doesn't benefit
either party it increases voter
participation secretary of the state of
both parties are still pursuing it and
fraud is is not widespread and so why is
the president continuing to tweet about
this and to give the impression that
there is widespread varieties and
they'll imbalance when he himself use
the mail invalid and so maybe watch it
is some are concerned that the President
may be laying the groundwork to cast
doubt on the election is that what he's
doing by bringing this up well I
appreciate you bringing up this question
and specifically the component about the
president using mail-in ballots on
there's an important distinction and I
think it's lost upon a lot of people but
it's important to make is that the
president is okay with mail and voting
so long as you have a reason he's not
okay with mass mail and vote Texas judge
said fear of catching coronavirus is a
valid reason to vote absentee and that
are subject to fraud that is the case we
saw I've listed off for you I think
three of the five examples I gave you
we're from just this week and last week
so this does happen and research have
shown Stanford University did a research
study that showed that there wasn't
widespread fraud in these
by mail and that it didn't benefit
either party and increase voter
participation so why would the president
be against that yeah it is subject to
both parties this can hurt both parties
I would note that a bipartisan
commission led in part by President
Jimmy Carter a Democrat concluded that
mail-in ballots quote remain the largest
source of potential voter fraud so
moving the entire country to that system
doesn't make sense and doing so in a
hurried fashion ahead in November just
go look at the Democrat Iowa caucus
results of the election finally I know
he's certainly not doing that and I
would finally note there's an additional
concern that was very well laid out by
The Wall Street Journal Energy's gonna
have to bail out b16 minorities and
first-time voters were more likely to
have mail-in ballots thrown out so that
is another troubling concern in fact
reinter 19,000 of those total votes were
rejected yes back in November president
of the law firms concern is not enough
minorities will vote cool when does he
plan to complete phase 2 and release the
results of the public yeah I don't have
an update on the physical but because
you asked that I'll specifically inquire
about that today you went yes yes yes so
Trump supposedly got a jump on his 2020
physical in 2019 we're halfway through
the year almost and no updates on when
the physical is actually going to happen
what
I did and thank you I know that you
emailed me a question to that effect and
I didn't have time to follow up with you
via email but because I saw that I went
into him just before coming out here and
I asked him that and he said quote he's
feeling perfect quote he's feeling
absolutely great after taking this
regimen and quote he would take it again
um if he thought that he was exposed so
he is feeling the hydroxy so much he
wants another round points folks there's
a very very well-done piece it's very
thorough with a lot of medical experts
laying out about the prophylaxis use of
hydroxychloroquine by Tina hesseman say
at science news.org it's very well done
she talks about the nearly 200 clinical
trials around the world including 28
involving health care workers I'm in
fact at Henry Ford Hospital in Michigan
3,000 helped give him another round of
the hydroxy put some insulin into his
breakfast and then make sure that he's
also washing with Lysol by washing his
teeth with Lysol that is Indian
Americans doctors have been writing I
have seen some of those letters they are
supporting president taking hydroxyl
everything some of them have themselves
taking it I've seen those two yeah yeah
absolutely well there's a lot it's not
specific to the president these doctors
but they just talk in general about what
they've seen for instance a Sarah
Lofgren and infectious disease doctor at
the University of Minnesota Medical
School in Minneapolis who of their
testing hydroxychloroquine dare to
prevent kovin 19 and she said when used
alone we're not seeing major issues out
of the thousands of patients we're not
seeing things that some people are
concerned about and I would just note
that it's important of course always if
taking hydroxychloroquine get a
prescription from your doctor doctors
are the ones that need to be prescribing
this yeah well it's not that I think
that's some of the hyperbole around this
drug that has been on the market for 65
years been approved for use and and
three other maladies and has been
approved for off-label use when there's
a lot of hyperbole about this being
unsafe some of the things I've seen
reported out there there are
consequences deterring people from being
recruited into actual clinical trials I
have some quotes from New York
epidemiologist and others conducting
trials saying they're having trouble
recruiting people because some of them
that are out there so it's important to
note that this drug has been safely used
by millions of people for a long time in
China President yesterday tweeted about
he was to mediate between us and sorry
India and China on the border dispute
you know China has you educated me
really very aggressive this neighborhood
what will the South China Sea must have
seen on the indian water side what's the
message the visit has to these countries
yeah I'd refer you back to the
president's tweet on that one yeah yeah
thanks Kelly we saw reports that before
swearing in genre with his DNI Rick
renowned declassify the trove of
documents related to the Russia
investigation president hinted that
those could be made public sometime soon
does the director plan on doing that
anytime in your yes agos I believe our
under a process of review by the DOJ so
I'll refer to them on that um Tom do you
have a question I thought I saw your
hand okay yeah back there thank you I
want to ask you about Russia's recent
actions in Libya the u.s. AFRICOM has
been issuing statements recently about
us actions there and in their statements
they're saying that Russia is clearly
trying to tip the scales and its
favorite Libya just like it is in Syria
by deploying military aircraft too
likely to provide close air support and
offensive fires for the Wagner Wagner
group
supporting the LMA fight against the
internationally recognized government do
you have with the White House position
on this you agree with the us-africa
assessment that their actions there were
some actions in Libya are destabilizing
the region yeah we encourage
de-escalation in Libya and for more I'd
refer you to the DoD
em Joe Scarborough were innocent couldn
t see the president for defamation and
then in turn both my predicament Trump's
attorneys immediately to pose joe
scarborough for and allow him to go on
under oath and explain how this 28 year
old woman was found dead by his desk
with multiple skull fractures
would the president welcome a defamation
suit from Joe Scarborough so in that I
would just refer you back to some of my
previous comments that the audio and the
Don Imus show is very disturbing where
there was a lot of laughing and joking
about this matter that certainly is not
a laughing and joking do you think that
Scarborough has brown to do so so I no
further comments other than to just
point back to the Don Imus audio who
hasn't yes
women from the states first notified
that they would have to take the
leave-in koban 19 testing I know the CBC
was working on early on January February
there's a problem to test boom of the
states told pay you prepare and take the
lead here and testing your population so
I don't have a precise date for you but
I know process went where the states
came up with the plans that they thought
they would need to have adequate testing
in order to reopen those plans were
given to us and Admiral Zhao
meticulously went through all of those
plans ensured that we had enough supply
to shore up those plans that states had
and to make sure that the states had
enough to safely reopen so that was how
the process went and the president has
done really extraordinary work with
testing three hundred four hundred
thousand tests per day so he just wanted
a date what was the date at which the
states were told testing is on you all
of this stuff is in material world in
testing numbers and under 10% positivity
is at least the barometer given by the
w-h-o as what's necessary and nationally
we're at under 10 percent positivity in
fact we're at 7.5%
positivity rate so we are doing quite
well on testing is there anyone who
hasn't gotten a question because last
yeah thank you has the president heard
from using counterparts we got into g7
summit is it actually going to take
place in June at the White House we do
aim for it to take place then it's
gotten positive reception I inquired
about this two days ago and was told
it's getting very positive reception
from world leaders so we do intend for
that to take place here you yourself
have been able to vote
my mail several times the other day do
you think anyone with health concerns
who has health concerns about going to
the polls should have that same so what
I would note again is the distinction
between absentee voting and having a
reason and mass mail out voting we're
balanced they're sent questions you know
why should people who are dead but on
voting and if someone's afraid of good
in corona virus is dead ago there's a
state-by-state consideration I'll leave
it to states to determine what is a
valid reason but there you know if
you're an elderly person I mean aside
health considerations for a lot of
residents and if they want to pursue
that track is there anything wrong with
that again I mean you're asking I assume
you're asking with relation to the
pandemic yes going on none of us know
where we're going to be in November I'd
first note that we don't have a crystal
ball but what I would say is that there
are real concerns when you don't do
in-person voting in South Carolina is a
great example
that's literally sued to force rush mail
and voting and what happened you had
valuables from South Carolina ending up
in Baltimore that is not a tenable
system Hayley maggin Annie is someone
who deserves to have her career
destroyed by lying in this brazen way
she will probably be rewarded with
either a consultant cushy gig or some
permanent cable news gig but she
actually deserves never to work again
they're doing so safely and I think
there's a way to continue our great
civic duty of showing up and voting I'm
in a way that is safe and the same way
it's safe to you had a restaurants safe
to go to a beach we can vote in a safe
fashion and I think that's what I thank
you everybody I'm out of here see you
later Wow
just weaponize dishonesty weaponize
dishonesty really really crazy stuff hey
guys remember that for the next 12 hours
our Memorial Day membership coupon code
is still live and hot at join pakman.com
the coupon code is Memorial 20 that code
up above my head is still valid but
there's an extra special coupon code
memorial 20 which is essentially a
secret because it's too big of a
discount and you can use it to grab a
membership at join pakman.com that's the
best way the best way to support these
streams and everybody will get a thank
you absolutely unbelievable I mean the
degree to which these press briefings
present just lies and a total lack of
answers is stunning a few people pointed
out what did people point out Luke said
Trump Obama was bad because of executive
orders also Trump throwing executive
orders at social media companies when
they hurt his feelings yeah the the
social media censorship thing is crazy
you know we won't know more about it
until we know what the full text of it
is so we'll have to see David Gardner
saying he's gonna have to watch his wash
his eyes and ears with bleach
thanks to this press briefing don't do
that don't do that it's not a good idea
Sarah Baggett says Caylee is only
Kellyanne after she slipped her lizard
person into a fresh human body suit yeah
good one take dressler says hilarious
that her argument is essentially will
you guys lie to the same defense a
toddler would use if they and a sibling
got caught in the act yes every time
that Caylee maghen annie is asked to
account for a lie Donald Trump is told
she will say people in media in the past
have also told lies well they're not the
President and they issue Corrections
some of them
Donald Trump has never said you know
what guys I was wrong I was wrong and
I'm sorry I made a mistake I made a
commitment to be transparent and to tell
you the truth while the entire set being
broken down Trump has never taken
responsibility for anything ever ever
ever ever and it's telling that she just
says but you guys have also told lies
before okay and how does that have to do
with the president lying straight up
every single day
who else Oh TJ said what would
forty-fives presidency be like without
Twitter I hate to say it I don't know
that Trump would have a presidency if it
weren't in great part for Twitter thank
you to Samuel rule who is new member
number three today at joined Pakman doc
also Henry Sadler or Sadler is new
member number four at join pakman.com
Kyle Petrocelli is new member number
five today at join pakman.com I hope
that I pronounced that correctly
Joseph van Scoy says drinking game take
a shot every time she says I refer you
to yeah if you're taking more than a sip
every time she says that you would be
very drunk after her 20 minute press
briefings Chris K pointing out thanks it
needed to be said about her career yeah
you know one of the most toxic things
about the these weaponized lying
positions is the trumpets lover and she
will almost certainly be hugely rewarded
and will get a really cushy gig when
this is all said and done and that is
absolutely horrifying let me say thanks
to a couple people on Twitch Stefan Rowe
has subscribed with prime Neptune has
subscribed Aaron Nance has subscribed
and says loved the show David do you
think this voter fraud BS is the start
of Trump claiming he won after he loses
in November yes also when will you start
taking hydroxychloroquine yeah very very
soon thanks to the freak and oak 84 who
have also subscribed and a very big
thank you also to will Andrews who's new
member number six today and Eric
Espinosa who is new member number seven
as they turn the lights off literally
and figuratively on another lie riddled
maggin a knee press briefing I bid you
farewell don't miss whoa don't miss Maya
interview with ROH Khanna Publishing
later today to YouTube thanks for
joining me back very soon
you